Wie bitte den urknall gab es nicht und stattdessen den bounce was bitte ist das denn das meint jedenfalls
professor paul steinhart inhaber der albert einstand professor an der princeton university in den usa
Seiner ansicht nach gibt es zahlreiche physikalische probleme bei einem urknall die aus der urknalltheorie
ein wahres kuddelmuddel machen wieso weshalb warum jetzt in klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Eigentlich gibt es keinen zweifel daran dass universum ist aus einem urknall entstanden und nach dieser unglaublichen explosion hat sich unser universum
geredet vor
13,8 milliarden jahren doch der urknall macht probleme mit entwickelt hat diese theorie professor paul
steinhart inhaber der albert einstein professor an der princeton university in den usa
einer der
renommiertesten physiker weltweit doch er ist unzufrieden mit seiner theorie der
inflations theorie es hat einfach hinten und vorne auf den ersten blick hielten wir inflation für eine elegante und
Einfache lösung doch wie so oft steckt der teufel. Im detail das problem
Des urknalls ist das was in dem moment dieses kanals passiert die
quantenmechanische effekte die in unserem ausgedehnten universum nahezu zu vernachlässigen sind die führen dort zu einer
unmöglichkeit es würden sich zahlreiche
universen bilden deren unwahrscheinlichkeit oder wahrscheinlichkeit gleich ist ein
multiversum und das ist fatal es gebe keinerlei möglichkeiten irgendetwas
vorauszusagen beziehungsweise aus diesem ereignis schlüsse auf unser universum zu ziehen wie schon albert einstein sagte
Gott würfelt nicht und genau das passiert wenn die
quantenphysik zum tragen kommt albert einstein fand diese theorie damals gar nicht gut und die kosmologie möchte auf keinen fall eines von vielen
universum was so oder so sein könnte mit einer gewissen wahrscheinlichkeit nur
auf keinen fall und die astrophysik spielt ihnen in die hände dennoch sind keinerlei gravitationswellen aus der entstehungszeit
des universums gefunden worden so genannte primo die aale
Gravitationswellen und die müsste es geben wenn es den urknall gegeben deshalb forscht paul steinhart jetzt nachdem bauens den helder
inzwischen für die
wahrscheinlichere erklärung für die entstehung des universums und
Es wäre dann gar nicht die entstehung des universums gewesen stattdessen würde sich unser universum
ausdehnen und wieder zusammenziehen und das eben zu einem winzig kleinen punkt oder sogar
Zu einer singularität also einen punkt ohne ausdehnung entscheidend ist aber jetzt die art und weise der ausdehnung die erfolgt nämlich
laut seiner hypothese vergleichsweise langsam jedenfalls
So langsam dass keine quanteneffekte zum tragen kommen es entsteht kein
multiversum sondern eben nur unser einziges homogenes universum mit all den tollen eigenschaften die
vorhersagbar sind yahoo
Demnach gibt es eben kein multiversum sondern unser universum das quasi von bounce zu bauens atmet und sich immer wieder
zusammenzieht und ausdehnt immer und immer wieder
Dann gäbe es auch nur schwache primor die aale
Gravitationswellen uns wäre erklärbar warum wir sind noch nicht gefunden hätten einst scheint mehr immer deutlicher zu werden wir stehen an einem
scheidepunkt der astrophysik paul steinhart hat
2007 zahlreichen vorhersagen über entdeckung gemacht die es bereits vor fünf jahren hätte geben sollen entdeckung der dunklen materie
herstellung von dunkler materie
Erklärungen der herkunft der dunklen energie die erforschung des urknalls und ob es ihn überhaupt gegeben hat und die entdeckung von
gravitationswellen nur eine seiner vorhersagen ist eingetreten mit verspätung die entdeckung der
gravitationswellen in allen anderen fragen sind wir kein müll weitergekommen nichts mehr
Pustekuchen ja vielleicht sind wir bei diesen themen einfach auf dem holzweg und liegen vollkommen falsch oder
wir sind sogar an unsere grenzen gestoßen
Werden wir vielleicht nie erklären können woraus die dunkle materie besteht woher die dunkle energie kommen der urknall oder?
Rebounds hier bei pixum werde es jedenfalls erfahren wenn ihr kein video dazu und auch zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann dürfen wir hier
ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
Genau auf die glocke nur dann werdet ihr auch immer über neue videos informiert hier geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken big bang theory
Urknall aufgedeckt naja laut steinhart wäre das dann ein irrtum gewesen aber seht euch selbst hat ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dann